[Music]
and in photographic memory news
submitted by classic JK a store clerk
memorized the credit card info from over
1300 people Oh to buy things online
[Music]
right they should be hired by somebody
like an individual FBI mm-hmm and you
don't even have that much time to look
memorizing this dood memorized the name
the numbers the expiration and the mr.
Kent really is a photographic memory he
was going to town buying aa type of [ __ ]
what was he buying though so he was
buying things to sell to pawn shops so
he was trying to make cash up to peers
right like he was living off of this
where he failed is he aimed too low
right he aimed too low he could have
done card counting yeah yeah yeah stole
from the casinos make millions of
dollars I would have bankrolled um it's
legal to gorgeous memorize the right
credit card with a person that has
enough minor they probably wouldn't
notice you screaming off the top or
memorize the right things on the test
get good grades become a good citizen
make a lot of money
it's just not that fun dude when you say
it like that that's excuse XE how did
you get caught so he got caught because
people noticed he bought something hey
someone's taking my car yeah if you
bought two expensive shoulder bags
valued at 2500 I had them delivered to
his apartment which is that's how he
went down he's a European he's Japanese
yeah so this is no crime in Japan hi
Jesse I would have done something
clearer is more ambitious I just
wouldn't remember the number and then
just end up on my uber eats account now
which would have been eaten on who you'd
have to get delivered like don't pay
yeah so it was kind of funny so this
dude really looks like Julia's voice oh
really looks like melted ugly Nelson
though yeah what kind of bite is that
that's like a pucker bite that's me even
under bite all over but he's under and
over biting outside like it looks like
you know when you fill your mouth with
um [ __ ] chewing tobacco use big
league it's always like that imagine
feeling about the bubble gum how much
did he make out of his everything
did he calculate I don't know that
number but I just do know that he once
they raided his apartment they found a
notebook that had information of over a
thousand three hundred people I see this
is where you [ __ ] up here oh [ __ ]
that's a charge for every number in
there that you got why did you write it
down if you're good with memory yep
photographic memory leave it up here you
stupid ass and do it with one card bro
memory good enough for a certain amount
of time and then you write it down get
home and then write it down before
that's what you need to [ __ ] do it in
code stupid-ass subpoena i groomed this
guy like I could make I could be a big
brother and I couldn't beat your
percentage exactly big role and do it
legally and what do you steal you steal
what people don't notice okay you take
one point zero zero zero zero one cent
from every single [ __ ] credit card no
this is what you should do this is the
smart thing you use the card you put it
to your Eva your cash app or your paypal
and you just send yourself some money
busted I know that everybody in here is
not single right y'all in relationship
is dead he's very single right there
okay let me tell y'all this girl told me
this this is a true thing and I have
confirmed it with other women if they do
this if you ask to drop on her phone
number like a man you know and they say
give me your phone on my number in your
palm
she says she'll take dudes phones get in
their cash app and send herself like
$607 are driving but just like a Polly
Club they're like yes yes so be kept
would you ask is not proper phone number
you put in your phone don't give them
your phone he charged that back I don't
know I mean well you can request it but
you can't get it so yeah that's a whole
thing it's a whole ordeal i jack off the
porn they're smart dangerous don't they
the real life is too dangerous I was
crazy out there yeah but you were gonna
say they give them every number except
for oh they change one number that was
back in the day now they're coming after
your money and this is the penalty of
things to a lot of girls in LA they go
out with different dudes just so they
can buy them free food that hungry
in LA but there was this one guy I was
on - but you've been going on a lot of
dates just to get free meals but it was
a guy I'm like damn dude I gave to
charity I have girls they'd be like they
were like you know if I do like somebody
produced by Ramirez lighting my dams
like I'll let them take me down here's a
flight you like they it's like a whole
thing that's a whole lot of work for
dinner dude they gotta get ready they
got a [ __ ] dryer there they got a lot
of time to [ __ ] go to dinner that's a
whole lot of what if it's a nice dinner
yeah well if you like they'll Frisco's
or something that's like 60 bucks for a
whole lot of work what if they don't
give a [ __ ] and then you show up in
sweatpants
I don't like whatever feed me hey Pig
hey are they gonna receive a [ __ ] or
something or just nothing happened
what's the transaction she like eats her
food farts and goes home welcome welcome
to 20 she's good company I'd do it okay
if she makes me laugh I'd pay for it
yeah or you could jerk off to porn which
is always a guarantee okay and I like
guarantees yeah you because I know
you're gonna finish but the thing is you
get to go on a date you get to
conversate like I look forward to
talking and Enki like what about the
converse but you go ahead no
conversation porn you get descend you
sit there and you go hi porn I like to
donate on Twitch and y'all donate on the
webcams have you seen that ASMR that's
like ASMR husband we're like it's for
like single girls to watch and like he
just is your husband he's like hey baby
was your day today and like there's
enough time for the girl to talk back or
like or the guys oh my god that's
darkest yeah and then he's like oh
that's so I'm sorry about that that's so
cool that you today he talked me back to
and he has a conversation with them
imagine heute like this is a one-sided
conversation he ends up taking the
conversation in a completely dark place
and you're person listening to it like
yeah so I just murdered a hooker and
it's married in the backyard now are you
like it's okay anyway photographic
memory is a pretty dope skill I wish I
had this Steve always says I have it and
I don't I think you just have a good
memory I have a good memory the file
thing like triggers like a bunch of
memories but I don't have like if you
showed me a picture I couldn't tell you
every detail on that picture unless
super super super hard unless I knew
what was going on and we were like
trying really hard if you got a
photographic memory I mean I'm good at
those games we're like you show me
something like I'm jacked like jackpot
I'm always getting it you have a good
scores on that you know what I'm really
good at making up memory that never
existed that's really good have you ever
had like a memory of something and then
you talk to somebody who was there and
then your account of it is way different
than theirs yeah I hate him in the house
well did you know that memory is
actually 50% right I've heard about this
tell me more
there's a black mirror episode about it
really this is just talking about the
memory there like eyewitness accounts
and things like that they don't work
they just don't work because people will
call people out of the lineup that they
think all this stuff right and if your
IQ is low you can be manipulated and you
can have memory implanted in you that's
crazy
Brendan Dassey all that stuff so there's
already a whole series on Netflix about
this part where people get manipulate oh
that's just watch that but into
believing that yeah then they confess to
things that they never did ever want to
go home yeah so people have low IQ
they're very suggestible they can vote
they can be bacon you can implant memory
in them and on top of that or we can't
trust our own memories also because
whatever we're feeling at the moment
that is the the story that we tell
ourselves so we could look at one thing
like oh we went to this trip together
right but if you're being negative you
could be like that trip sucked right but
then if you're having a positive time
you could look back and go all that trip
was good that's right a lot of people do
that my ex was like that yeah oh my good
and then he would change it later and be
like we had a good time on that trip my
the [ __ ] you just said it was at that
time the moment he was at village yeah
and so memory is like you can't rely on
it you know it's really hard my cousin
Vinnie is like that
your cousin Vinnie well the movies
I was like she has so many cousins there
could be one holding true play by Joe
Pesci just recently my husband and I had
this whole thing about a memory
situation where I'm like I could have
sworn you said this like I reven
remember the whole situation what I
where I was standing what I was doing
what he said my thoughts on it but what
if it was just a tree I was just like I
remember you said this and it was
because of this reason he's like I swear
he didn't say it that's it and you guys
bought pop you feel so passionately
about what you do because it's your own
memory and what you think is real but
see the thing is like I mean logically I
would believe him over me because my
memory is not that reliable right now
but for this one thing I'm like I know
perfect you [ __ ] said it I know you
did like thank you let it go the best
[ __ ] know is that it's such a cute thing
it's like we're gonna go sleep over a
part in Gio's house okay and I gotta
give it a go cuz I was just gonna brush
over it but there was this USC fight
that Steve I mean a Casey and Bart
really wanted to see and it was in Dubai
so it was gonna be in a really weird
hour 10 a.m. yeah well usually there's a
night these fights are at night so I
didn't know that it was in the morning I
just remember I was doing my makeup and
at the vanity and kids because my he's
like oh yeah by the way were sleeping
over in jails and I'm like oh we are why
that's weird and he was like oh cuz
we're gonna go watch a fight and it's at
a really weird hour so I assumed that
was gonna be a very late fight and that
we were just gonna sleep over because
it's gonna be too late to drive back
home but then it turns out that it was
in the morning and so we're here last
week who's the last week yeah last week
during JK news and I'm like oh yeah
Casey said were sleeping over your house
and then they were like why when did
this happen like it turned into this
whole piece where we end up sleeping
over their house for the weekend
I called our place Chateau dela because
they're bears that bears I call it
because you sleep over a few times
comfortable
but anyway pounds moving so how was your
memory but there's somebody else's maybe
it was something different no no but his
memory because Casey's behind the camera
Casey's memory was that he never said
that we were sleeping over and then I
just made up the whole thing and I'm
like okay and I saw it all happened live
and it was just it was just as fun as
you know or you're both wrong nothing
ever happened or maybe he said something
similar but it was interpreted
differently or there's just so many
things good the funny thing is because
the funny thing is so I was there when
Casey was invited and it was the day
before we shot Jake a news yeah so then
when she mentioned that I was like
really and I'm like because I was there
and Bart didn't even tell Casey about
sleeping over yeah and then you're like
oh yeah he told me that like a week ago
and I'm like so he invited you thank you
actually you mentioned that whole vanity
thing was like right when they first
found out about the fight or something
cuz it was like way before just last
week so I'm like I [ __ ] know you said
I wish you could see Jesus did for now
he's like Casey I'm back I'm like hell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]